okay let's
let's hope this works
oh it's working oh my gosh okay
guys i've had some issues with some of
my like live reactions
um
so i'm excited i'm back and i'm better
okay so
oh my gosh today
i'm gonna be reacting to me being on
fresh and fit i've been traveling so
sorry um
i haven't had time to like react to this
but i've been wanting to react to like
sorry
um
oh let me pull up i'm gonna pull up the
comment section in um
my
on my phone so i can like see you guys
oh gosh this phone's at two percent
let's see
if this phone's any better
i think there should be a way that i can
like watch at the same time but
me and technology also
i need you guys to
tell me how the audio levels are i've
been getting some complaints about my
audio levels
so
um
i really need you guys to just tell me
how they are
okay so videos
okay
where are we
where's the one that i was on
it's organized by sort by
new best yeah i saw like two weeks ago
maybe
um
[Music]
i was told i betrayed fresh and fit
when i made that one video but it's
funny because
like one i only met the guys like twice
so i don't know why people were like
saying i betrayed these people that i
literally don't know at all
and then the second thing
like i think podcasters in general
assume a lot more loyalty from just like
going to someone's podcast
you know what i mean
um and i was gonna do like
my fresh and fit experience video after
anyways
so it's like i like told them that going
on so it's kind of funny that people
were like oh you betrayed them i'm like
okay
i'm just telling them about my
experience anyways um this is the first
time i went on
so
i'm gonna be reacting to this before we
start i need you guys to tell me how the
audio levels are can you hear me let me
know in the
drop the jaw comments up my unit also if
you hear anyone yelling that's my
brothers
they're annoying but
these are five you know i can't really
i probably spilled like a gallon and a
half okay so i'm gonna play the video
really quick before it starts
and tell me if you can hear me and the
video okay like if the audio levels are
okay
hey what's up guys welcome to freshwater
podcast after hours edition we got a
packed house we got a great show planned
for you guys a lot packed yes let's get
into it
okay and then this is gonna be my voice
any complaints
any complaints
also does this help if i talk like
closer to the mic
let me know in the comments
[Music]
i
[Music]
the video is too loud compared to your
voice okay let's fix that before we go
so my mic is all the way up so i cannot
make this any
but
oh [ __ ] is this the
let me let me test these audio levels
you're more than welcome i asked you to
stop with the question and you didn't do
it that's serious go put your shoes on
outside you don't got to put them on in
here all right how about now
[Music]
luke let me know is this better can you
guys the audio level's good
hey what's up guys welcome to pressure
podcast after hours edition welcome to
the show don't forget to
dislike the video on your own
thank you guys so much for all the
support okay so this was during the
midst of their whole controversy
oh my gosh and before the show they were
definitely talking hella [ __ ]
oh my gosh
uh whether you support or not thank you
so guys quick announcements before we
get into the show patreon.com make sure
to check us out over there where we have
behind the scenes stuff on the shows
frank castles zoom calls we talk to you
guys about real estate investing making
money cryptocurrency uh dating getting
girls we just dropped the fire episode
for you guys a little while ago on how
to sugar date without tricking right uh
time stamps are in there it's all there
for you guys check it out a lot of gems
will drop yep credit cards real estate
teach you guys how to become a better
man in general so that you don't have to
trick you become the prize so that she
doesn't want you to pay for her time all
right okay so check us out there on
patreon also guys on spotify google and
apple podcast yes everywhere guys listen
to us there but remember put headphones
in because we might get fired yeah put
headphones on and as a matter of fact
get a screen protected how many people
are actually getting fired like
come on let's just that has a privacy so
they can't see so they can't see god
damn we're the most hated right now okay
so make sure
that you don't let people know you're
listening to us and also make sure to
dislike the video as well to show how
much you hate so uh guys also check us
out fresherpodcaststore.com
where you guys get all the merch man
ninja watch your t-shirts which uh yeah
the hoodies um for example t-shirts um
oh my gosh i didn't tell you guys this
fresh and fit totally commented on my
video calling me a clout chaser that i
made about my freshman fit experience
and then they deleted it like why are
you going to comment just to delete it
stand on your comment stand on it
t-shirts but i feel like but i feel like
t-shirts everything is there so check us
out on freshlypodcaststore.com uh vlog
channel guys behind the scenes of my
life trey's life farmer's life and
chris's life you can check it out there
some of our dates when we travel all
that stuff get a channel 50k let's go
yep check us out over there cool trey is
recovering guys by the way for some of
you guys that are wondering hey how's
straight doing don't worry back soon the
assassin i paid didn't do a good job so
uh he'll be back um twitch.tv slash
russian podcast podcast guys check us
out over there so you guys can see
titties in 1080p so make sure you guys i
was so nervous when this started i don't
know why i just
i get nervous okay but like look at me
oh my gosh so nervous what's that
pornhub tab and open up another tab
twitch.tv podcast check us out over
there growing over there as well we just
said what how many new followers twenty
two thousand thousand yeah thank you
guys for sticking with us and then uh
chris you wanna tell them about you
because find me on twitch aaron parks
and um this week i will get straight
i'll be streaming uh video reactions
gaming and stuff like that so follow my
instagram aaron c parks and to get
updates and let's get it cool and then
uh for now guys since trey is sick go
ahead and uh dm me on unplug fit with
three t's if you guys got video ideas
and reactions yeah we'll pick them and
uh you know we'll talk about it and then
we'll shout you guys out we'll put your
um instagram name in the description uh
if we just decide to uh use your video
to react to which we got a video today
uh which we'll talk about shout out to
our boy yeah shout outs our boy and then
ladies
ladies if uh you won't come to our show
uh send me a dm on instagram on um an
rnc parks and make sure that your
profile is on private sites i can see it
um and if you're flying into miami and
you have a husband or a boyfriend
make sure make sure to come with you all
right because we want no issues yeah
anything like that okay so let's bring
him with you uh and then bring him with
you did they say to tell them first
bring him with you i don't usually watch
the full show
bring him with you okay
sorry i just wanted
wanted to point that out guys on
instagram check us out freshratepodcast
uh on instagram uh make sure to send uh
all your hating messages and our
comments there calling us frauds helps
with the engagement i appreciate it
greatly uh okay
shout out to the mods hey yeah
[Music]
because y'all are definitely uh helping
out here we appreciate it
and twitch in the chat too yup
i will say guys i'm pale but i'm not as
pale as i look on camera
like the lighting in general in my room
and on these shows like does not do me
justice
like it makes me look whiter
hey man like like i told you i said it
before but bro hey man it's not about
waiting for the storm to pass it's about
learning how to dance in the [ __ ]
rain and right now we pop blocking on
this [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
category five hurricane in florida we
got window to we got uh hurricane oh my
gosh it was so funny before the show
they were all talking about how
like basically their mindset is like the
world is against us like they only hate
us because we're jealous and i'm like
thinking is it possible that
maybe you did something wrong i i don't
know just me impact windows we [ __ ]
ready baby we're killing are we chilling
right now i'm saying so uh yeah man
just as a wise man once said curtis
jackson right uh let him hate and watch
the money pile up so there you go man
whether you dislike the video like the
video whatever it doesn't matter
we appreciate it thank you so much so
anyway let's introduce the lovely ladies
on the panel cool and then i'll read the
super chats after okay so ladies give us
your name your age we do for living and
your current dating status and we'll
start right here
all righty my name is zarya i am 24
i'm a nurse and a model
and i am single all right oh [ __ ] okay
single gang
my name
is what adam if you want to mess up
again tomorrow
get out of here
sorry
i'm i'm doing a video why do you always
ruin my videos
sorry
you're not even in the video
you're not
but you're not you're just screaming
from the other room oh my god sorry guys
um that's my brothers they're annoying
in a class center but i'm also a
freelance makeup artist
thank you and um i'm
you said age
yes 19.
and she's drinking water guys i could
not believe she was 19. but people say i
look older too which is offensive but
i think it's partially because i dress
like an old lady and i don't wear makeup
or get dressed up i don't think it
what was the helps question i'm very
much single okay all right cool welcome
all right
my name is elijah i go by sunny um i do
a marketing specialist for digital
digital social media i'm 26. i also do
um music videos video vixen and i'm
taken
all right welcome
um i'm noelle
welcome back noelle
youtuber yeah i do youtube i also do
lobotomy now lobotomy
with the bodies yeah
damn don't mess with her bro this is
coming for your body [ __ ] you up oh man
so you're the person that sticks people
with needles yep oh man
yeah me and you are not gonna get along
and i'm single so okay all right
um so my name is pearl hey
welcome
i'm 24. um i do youtube full-time so my
channel's just pearly things
and um yeah i'm single
oh [ __ ] because for some of those
i was so nervous i know the chat's
saying i look nervous it's because i was
yeah i don't know why i've never been
like on a live
show before no yeah yeah she had a
boyfriend but we'll talk about that
anyway
and she just reactions to our videos too
yes she reacts to a bunch of content
creators in the space
welcome to the show welcome
hi guys welcome back hi my name is kim i
am 31 as of monday happy birthday
okay
thank you thank you now she looks
younger i thought she was like 25.
wait 31.
[Music]
i uh you know if you want for your
birthday gift i can enroll you in the
senior citizen home
[Music]
and um i'm a commercial lifestyle model
and what was another one oh i'm single
still guys okay still it's okay we'll
find you welcome back thank you all
right
hi
uh she's so icy
uh i'm 26 professional pole dancer
and i'm single
okay
all right and yo guys just you know just
so you know she went up a bunch of
flight of stairs man she's in shape yeah
yeah man
every night
i was out of breath
okay people are asking in the chat so at
this point um
i
was
single because
i was moving to england
and
where i am i'm moving to england
and so you know
had to you know end it at that point but
you know
then we got back together but my
brothers
okay read the super chats real quick uh
thank you guys for all the support man
we really really appreciate it the real
ones are in the house man
uh okay let's see here uh the cia
attention middle eastern myron we notice
you prancing around the president
uh presidential palace and kabul over
the weekend please contact our office
immediately we'd like to talk appreciate
that c.i.a
now middle eastern irons on the on the
run uh michael k in a cave somewhere
michael keanus two dollars white is
grown earth on fresher fit oh snap yeah
she's haircut yeah she's the whitest no
no and she is the camera show so what no
the camera makes me slightly more pale
slightly not much but slightly
uh mr williams spider is fresh man i
have to say you shoot with sleazy king
of page what i have to say your shoot
was steezy king of page out my closet as
for the show meyer and keep beating the
bs out man and let's keep this going
absolutely i appreciate it uh l e i uh l
e i o uh ladies what's your life like
the good the bad and the ugly i think
means ugly um and we'll talk about that
um we got uh five hours from melvin pick
uh for the algorithm i appreciate
everything guys thank you so much we got
mattias uh fagion with the big uh
y-u-u-u-y-u
150 super chat i don't know just showing
some love yeah we'll figure it out right
now we got people from all over the
world here while uh mediocres react hard
workers create keep it up absolutely
you're a gry and peso we make the
content that they react to just remember
that guys black wolf inc five dollars uh
ready to proudly serve as the fresh and
fit biggest thank kevin samuels to
develop more of the ideas in the
nanosphere to be honest whole mod
tonight the blocks are going to be on
delightful [ __ ] them northern boys it's
over 9000
um thank you so much how do you dislike
a video before even starts so quick to
pass judgment keep doing your thing
brothers love seeing people from our
community working hard absolutely and
guys don't forget to like the video
dislike the video on your way in or like
it either or it helps us out um esquito
uh rusco quarterly check in lads fresh
fit gang forever man after haters don
demarco for the hustle absolutely thank
you so much now we're gonna do three
shows for you guys tomorrow i'll make a
quick announcement on that three true
great ten dollars canadian someone's
still salty making reaction vids that
should tell you everything we still
fresh and fit gang shout out to canada
oh man cia once again still waiting for
the green light
i get so impatient when they read the
chats i'm like
like i'm happy for them that's so great
it's just like and you know
thomas sanchez five bucks tattoo face is
a clown girl in a clown world well
you're a clown as well oh [ __ ]
um tree goal go not uh haters really be
clowning do they well okay and i don't
have a problem with building off of
people's ideas like everyone's ideas
comes from somewhere that's the whole
point of being in a particular
you know in a particular group like
liberals build off of each other's ideas
conservatives build off of each other's
ideas it's pretty normal
to build off of each other's ideas and
come up with your own little caveats
like
not everyone can think that differently
you know um
i just hate when people will like clown
each other for like you know copying
when it's like
how how original are your ideas
really how original are they not
realized by being here they're giving
you more exposure and helping algorithm
let me out no bro don't tell me hey hey
hey hey don't tell that to them bro bro
what are you doing
uh
uh okay let's see here we got uh what's
next um
can we get an alternate intro for your
new villain arc hey you know what man
man oh i'm gonna answer all the
questions people have about this because
i had so many comments and i was gonna
address them but i was like
not really am i salty that myron hurt my
feelings oh i was oh my gosh right after
the show i was so salty
but
i don't really see why that matters like
like i think anyone would be salty if
you scream at them like duh maybe bro
baby man you know it's like stone cold
when he when he uh
said when he joined that with vince
mcmahon and he turned on the rock at
wrestlemania 17.
apparently we're evil so yeah that is
what it is man in that case if we're
evil
mr williams at two dollars what's good
just barely bought about time you got on
hey uh mr fourth quarter five hours oh
yeah i'm still here let's go i work from
home so they can't see my screen
absolutely tomorrow real ninja time
gently five hours the zoos has entered
the chat thank you
and another sorry sorry to keep building
on this but i'm reading the chat as i as
i react to this another thing
if you have good ideas you should want
people
to spread those ideas
like
you really should to be honest if it's a
good idea and one that you want a lot of
people
to know you should want other people to
spread it
uh mckenna yeshua
people gonna hate yeah uh see latvian
english that's life dance compa on them
god bless absolutely here we go uh man's
doing god's work pressure fit keeps uh
keeps me sane and grounded in reality
hey we try bro lactose tolerant black
men okay
these names are awesome
pro looks like she's fresh out the
polygamy ranch
cover for you exploring the map uh 20
australians so will the ladies give up
social media or makeup don't worry we'll
talk about that that's a good one and
then uh and then we've got citroen
create still rocket with y'all bring
kevin samuels back more respectful
disagreements lesbian yep control all
create yeah um and then we got logan g
start love the podcast must be protected
at all costs absolutely we ain't going
nowhere randy here much love from los
angeles and then uh joseph buman first
time seeing you guys live looking
forward to the show as always appreciate
everything you guys do i mean you make
money and whatnot but that does not
undercut the uh undercut the value that
you guys provide and that we shall
continue to do so quick announcement
guys we got 5000 you guys in here
already
please
dislike the video comment below saying
frauds and we appreciate the support uh
with that said guys we got bricks
fitness in the house we're gonna have
him on the show tomorrow five five p.m
then we're gonna do a show with our
trusted freshman fit ladies at 7 00 pm
and then we're going to do a late night
show for you guys at the regular timer
on 10 or 10 30. so we're gonna do three
shows for you guys tomorrow uh you know
we're gonna keep working um and then la
okay and that from this point forward
chris what do you want to do
okay so let's get into the first
question then i'll read those super
chats
so ladies uh right now in your life
right give us the priority of getting
married for you is it number one on the
list last on the list what's the
priority for you to get married i will
start
me yeah okay
my priority to get married is very last
on the list to be real with you due to
my profession i see a different side of
men so it it discusses me to be real so
i'm just focused on me and my son and
just trying to get it right okay so
you're focusing on your kid
marriage is not a man that's not really
the idea right now do you ever think you
could ever get to that point where you
would want somebody maybe but honestly
until i get out the game i feel like
that's when amanda's gonna take me
serious so since i'm here hustling i'm
not gonna go for it i tried it i don't
want to try no more i'm done okay
all right
oh it's not a priority
right now
just i mean
it's not a priority period can you also
just add to it what are your top well
you kind of said it your child and and
and work what what are your top i guess
two or three priorities yeah
um at the moment right now my career and
just development like self development
like
yeah okay confidence self
self-development and yeah get into this
money okay so so self-improvement from a
financial aspect yes is that is your
primary yes thing and then when you when
you say self-improvement because there's
so many different facets of that yeah
well yes um financial yeah financial
improvement okay
yeah because yeah pretty much financial
so improving your career and
and also to improve with finances okay
cool yeah
um
i would say
get some
deep right this made me so uncomfortable
oh my gosh
because they project their like miami
thoughts onto like
me
so
they're like oh they kept making jokes
and i was just trying to like
never it just irritated me
[Music]
now that you're back on the market
um
no
i don't know i don't know what to say
no i need to pull my card you're making
me uncomfortable like uh no
no no no i would say like
right now my priority is
youtube like i'm trying to grow my
channel i'm also trying to get in like
probably the best shape of my life is
michael
um and then like i do want to get
married in the next like
24 so three or four years i would say
okay all right fair enough here
so but but right now the top two
priorities are youtube and fitness and
fitness no i'd maybe put like a
relationship a second okay and i thought
about this i thought about this later i
was like what does it mean to put a
relationship first like how much time
can one really spend in a week like
dating
like
even if let's say i went on you know
because at this point i was single right
what if i went on five dates a week
that's still
less time than i'm spending at a 40-hour
work week job
and if you're dating someone that also
is working like how how much
okay it's just my two cents okay yeah so
youtube relationship second yeah and
then you guys stop eva is not of age get
you my sister she's 17. then the fitness
yeah okay
first
marriage is not a priority right now
because i want to make you know the
right choice for who you marry um but i
would say my top priorities probably my
business that i'm creating
and yeah finances you know making sure
my life is together adulthood so
yeah okay how about your um youtube my
youtube i'm still working on my youtube
i'm trying to rebrand it so
yeah for the people out there you do do
you still do the interviews um with
people in public i haven't lately
no why he's created the um
outrageous questions no well
it's kind of like i flirt on the beach
and i try to like you know go up to guys
because they don't expect a girl would
you go on a date with me yeah those type
of things yeah they like those but i
haven't done it in a minute
i told you that was like a great concept
yeah you should have kept doing it
mm-hmm i i am i just had to take a break
real quick mental mental break no
there's no bracelet there's no brakes on
this train not on youtube you gotta back
you better get back
how many subs are you at right now did
you break 100 you did right no no
92k
still sitting there when you were here
you were like at 90. exactly no i was
91. so i only got 100k between that time
yeah
okay guys don't worry after the show
because i can't do it on camera i'm
going to give her a couple of
slacking okay um um
right now marines i wouldn't say it's
like necessarily a priority um i feel
like you can know someone for a really
long time and still not know who they
are because their character traits are
still developing me as well like i think
mental health is so important and i've
experienced where someone can take you
out of your element and you are crazy so
i feel like just working on my own
character flaws
getting to know someone more than just
surface level because i've done that a
lot where i'm just like oh he looks good
he's there he's gonna skip the other
girls not going to never worry do you
need to really like understand what
someone wants and you want to rush
anybody but i don't think all women want
or look for marriage i do want it in the
future but i'm going to like work on
myself focus on like music videos
okay um and i do marketing for social
media i want to focus on that myself
mentally physically you only got
everybody one okay i kept looking at the
comments they told us not to before you
go on the show but
it's so hard i like i like reading
comments and if i'm giving it to
somebody forever you know you better be
like um you're supposed to be with me
because i need to feel your energy
how long have you been with your
boyfriend
okay
and i didn't know who they were so i
just like experienced but you didn't
know about the [ __ ] half years they
just changed when we met we were in
college we didn't drink he just ended up
being too much and you don't know until
someone until elements are brought into
your relationships
is this bothering you guys i can't i
just i'm trying to get back to her
ambitious in college and then you start
drinking and the work passes um no he
was like ambitious but the thing was it
was like basketball was his like dream
and then he kind of like messed himself
up during that and then he moved and
then he was kind of like i don't know
what i want to do and i feel like for
anybody who has a goal right now you
know
yeah but then he did other things that
he held in but he just was like
okay i think the views are going down
i'm gonna i'll go back i'll go back no
you're not going to go anywhere and
that's the mental health thing because
people can convince you that you're not
going to do something
so not from your experience you go for
not just looks but like someone has
integrity or someone else oh yeah
definitely character definitely i like
someone that's hilarious if anything
because i don't know anybody can be
toxic so i just need someone to not give
me any negative
toxicity because i just probably do okay
bringing me that energy you know okay
yeah
i had a dumbbell in her life then all of
a sudden she in the gym
it can be toxic so i just need someone
to not give me any negative toxicity
because i could be probably too if
someone was bringing me that energy you
know okay
cool yeah
all right shout out to uh black lemon by
the way oh
[Music]
welcome pearl when pro made that video
saying she was going to start getting
into great shape i knew the boyfriend
was about to go bye-bye
oh my gosh i've deviated guys
i've been too stressed with the move i
swear i'm gonna be in
really good shape
when i'm when i get to england because
i'm gonna be on a semi-pro sports team
but i i'd put it on the back burner i
had to move
yes there are many telltale signs that
your girl's about to leave you and that
is definitely one of them she never had
a dumbbell in her life then all of a
sudden she do
she in the gym lifted weights
i was so irritated i'm like dude i was a
former college athlete i dead lifted
like 300 pounds throughout the entire
i was
it's a rap freak
don't be stupid you know it's a wrap
okay virtual uh god of death became my
brother hey guys welcome to the freshman
fifth fam for all the real ones married
so so so hold on though what if your
partner wanted to get married good for
him
nobody or nothing else lives sprint free
in my head okay
some people would really need that
advice for it but uh that's okay uh okay
so let's hit some of these super chats
real quick uh we got um
yep
that just came out yo guys thank you so
much for the support bro um
okay so we got ian right okay eamon
simmons 20 that's enough pie for
everyone to eat all four of you black
successful men should be collaborating
and take over the world yeah you know it
is what it is uh nolan baptiste fresh to
fit keep your heads up you guys are
great thank you so much thank you
brother um daryl blake 10 hours noelle
welcome back babe okay see you look at
that people
babe uh d train fitness minor setback
shout out to fresher and brick no guys i
wasn't offended i was just like
get get out of here hey thank you so
much bro you guys are going to see
bricks tomorrow come on
rick's on the camera yeah bricks you
want to say what's up to the people real
quick man
come on man hey man shout out to bricks
fitness right now
[Music]
i had no idea
no idea
and guys used to be fat he has a really
great inspirational story guys that
we're going to talk about in detail
tomorrow make sure to check out that
interview it's going to get you guys
motivated so if you're out of shape and
you need some goddamn motivation we're
here to help you guys out because we are
about to fat shame the hell out of you
guys tomorrow be ready uh okay so what
else do we got here we got uh okay we
got um
okay so we got um uh j t d trinity the
best podcast in the world thanks fellas
for doing god's work thank you so much
trinity and then we got sunnyball in one
when's then
dan pena coming on uh actually
i was okay no let me not say that uh
hopefully soon
okay
get rid of the super chats other than
the one who already does um that's a
good question we could uh we could we'll
factor that in as well don't worry guys
we got some questions asked fresh go
ahead okay
so
we know your priorities now in life
right
so let's say you do me a guy they want
to take it seriously
what does he have to have do you say you
know what
i'm on my on my mission but i want him
to join to join me or like be a part of
his mission
what does he have to have in that sense
and we'll start here
um
well he has to have his stuff together i
really would like for him to be mentally
stable for one because
we can't both be crazy so
so yeah i would like to have this stuff
together um
this priority
i have a lifetime to be a basketball
player
[Music]
all
i
right
cool
that all right so that means he's got to
be at least six four
okay
and how tall are you i'm five five oh
okay all right
okay
hey man okay uh miranda so um are we
gonna ask income two i guess this is one
or no well basketball player is a pretty
um
are we talking professional very much
because i play basketball too okay
okay
i just want to make sure because
people that play ball yeah but they
ain't professional so six three and
quality six seven figures uh minimum
yeah okay you you oh okay that's on a
good team you know the ones that
actually oh andy's got to be on a good
team
wait wait
tell me if i'm wrong but i feel like the
quality of the show would go up if they
had less females a lot of the time
because i think it takes so long
and you spend so much time on the same
topic because there's so many girls but
if there's like two or three i almost
think it would be better
no
no as far as i know i probably won't do
nothing like that
stop the cow so you won't travel
i mean even bench players make pretty
decent money so i'm not gonna lie they
could sit there and still make some
money they don't know yeah they don't
even gotta play yeah most players are
still millionaires yeah
yeah that's totally fine
she want that star player though she's
one one yeah she wants the star
[Music]
sorry guys not good enough any guys that
one any nba players out here that is
that and you had to have compete in the
all-star game within the last two years
go ahead and hit her up guys dm talk
here only and if you don't got a blue
check she ain't going to respond okay so
uh
all right miranda can you say the
question
got you stupid
[Laughter]
so
you're on your purpose right you're
you're working you're doing your thing
what does that have to have you free to
say you know what damn i actually want
to be with him he just needs to be at my
level like
i'm not looking for anything specific
you got to be in the same type of time
my mom what time is that
hard time greatness
being the best you could possibly be all
the time
we're not only for you but for me too
okay okay okay
so
it can be short he can be out of shape
he can be i don't know
slow okay like i said i'm not looking
nothing specific
cap i mean you're not looking like okay
any man that i'm aligned with will be
the man that's for me doesn't matter
what he looks like like sometimes the
girls just say a whole lot of nothing
and like what she just said was a whole
lot of nothing but he should at least be
my height honestly
okay so we're getting somewhere there's
a little bit of a requirement uh yeah i
mean anything else that he has to
possess is a bare minimum that's that's
we're basically trying to get out here
you just gotta
i don't know there's no bare minimum
like specifically income i'm not gonna
answer that question hi i guess you
could say you know my height i'll tell
you five eight okay so like five eleven
six feet
yeah i guess he could be five nine
that's okay okay i'm not judging don't
care about style if he wears baggy
shorts and black air forces will that
work
i mean
like i said a man that's aligned with me
will have so you don't have black air
forces i definitely do not
sorry guys i tried for you hood guys out
there
that are checking us out
so okay so um any other requirements
that the guy has had so just five foot
eight and uh be destined for greatness
he needs to have himself together
can you define that for us
i was thinking the same thing like what
what does that mean stable coming to
heal they don't come to me at all okay
can't be crazy so no back no no nothing
crazy you know you can be stable and
crazy
everybody's crazy if you want to think
about it like that everybody got a
little crazy though
just you know be able to protect you
crazy
i mean it's called crazy for a reason
what the [ __ ] yes
yeah uh do you want us to come back to
you so yeah
have something ready okay yeah um sunny
why didn't you get that option
um
me personally someone that has it
together i don't really i've already
done tall guys basketball doesn't work
it can work for some people it didn't
work for me wait wait yeah okay you
didn't like your lifestyle like
it was just too much and like anyone who
i feel like is
at a goal
like for sports that's a lot of stress
and i feel like that brings it on your
relationship did he play um
did you go to a division in school um
yeah okay okay you don't have to share
if you don't want to but uh oh do you
want to say sure i mean you're out now
they can't stalk you denver metro okay
uh so he played he played ball for them
yeah okay so he was on the team yeah so
he had social status on okay yeah he was
good
team winning man yeah okay fair enough i
tried it more than once and i was like
you know what let me try it again this
person a little taller they play
basketball let me try that so about how
many times you tried it
twice okay so so you dated another
basketball player after three after
action it works
six nine
it works all right six nine you like
them tall i'm fine
okay people are asking my reasoning for
going on fashion fit um in the comments
um
i don't know i just thought it'd be
interesting
good exposure like
see if i could offer
any assemblance of a debate
but i don't care now like height doesn't
really matter to me
um you just gotta have yourself together
i don't mind if you
came to me and you have yourself
together but sometimes you go through
things and i feel like you can support
somebody because actually if i'm going
through something you're going to just
dip out because i'm going through
something i've got my [ __ ] together
because i might not always have my life
together so just somebody who
understands things that i'm going
through and actually wants to like
you gotta ride out you gotta be there if
you don't want to how tall is your guy
now um my guy is five nine and a
question
what do you see your current guy that
made you say you know what i want to be
with him um
acceptance like doesn't try to change me
i like i do music videos you know he's
so super supportive
you know i don't want anyone to try to
say like oh change this i've had people
say like
be you but be you privately i don't want
you to be you publicly and that's like
you know that's something else so
controlling yeah controlling people have
their own ways it's not it can't it's
not always controlling people have their
own ways i just need someone stable
enough to come to me at the right time
and for me to be where i want to be to
even
bring you in yeah like if i'm not gonna
you know no one wants to tell somebody
about themselves over and over and over
again it's just repetitive i just want
acceptance you like me for me we're good
we're whole we can do that together we
can do whatever you know and and just
that um curiosity so you said you dated
your college basketball player and then
the next guy the two basketball players
the next guy was he a division one
basketball player as well or was he
professional he was division one too but
when we met he we were he was on he was
out of college yeah okay all right okay
so fair enough yeah was he playing
basketball like overseas or something
like that um no he he wanted to but then
he wanted to go be a police officer so
we kind of switch it up okay and was he
in law enforcement when you when you
guys don't we talk we're friends but um
i don't know what he's doing like that
okay so your friends owned them after no
we friendzoned each other some people
are just better off as friends in a good
way not even no negativity they're
they're good they do their own thing i
do mine so your friends are your ex
we're friends they have a new girlfriend
like we're very very cool some people
are just meant that way i was half bored
half nervous like it takes so long to
get through all the girls like
be honest i wish we actually would have
became friends but we're like just
rushing it for no reason some people
just rush things it seems like a good
idea and
they don't have to be that way
on this podcast we tell you guys the
rush thanks
make sure you get on that date
immediately
last episode don't waste time yeah don't
waste time but okay we'll move on uh
okay what about uh for you for me i do
want somebody who's like mentally stable
uh so we can't be
what does crazy mean to you though crazy
i just feel like they're all over the
place like
just with their emotions they don't know
what they want they don't know if they
want to be with you they don't want to
be with you
indecisive yeah you know i don't i don't
like that um
you know know what they want to do in
life you know have ambitions i like
really smart guys i don't want to
athlete i don't
i don't want that lifestyle i tried that
already in you know high school days
after high school i don't want that um
it's funny to me how many girls have
been through that lifestyle and you're
like you know what i'm good yeah i
thought i wanted it but now this is nice
it's good for the moment like it's fun
entertaining but it's draining like it's
really draining okay i will say that
dating an entertainer
has given me a level of insecurity i
like didn't even know i had because it's
tough to know
you know like how girls will be sliding
in their dms and just like
at them all the time like it takes a
really secure person to not let that
bother them
you know like i had a girl hit on him
literally in front of me
like he didn't do anything right but it
was just like that level of disrespect
would never happen
in a normal relationship with them and
then other girls it's just too much i
don't like is it really draining dealing
with them or is it draining dealing with
the the competition
the competition too like because you
know all the girls want them as well and
you know they're not gonna focus on you
when they have bad days like if they're
like failing at a sport or something
then they're in their head all the time
it's just too much so i don't like that
oh welcome to being a guy when you have
a girlfriend
a special wife yeah
yeah lionheart feels three of them shout
out to mr organic man
[Music]
i was on the phone with him earlier him
a tall guy man they showed me that love
follow mr organic and tall guy card
reviews man
uh yeah that's pretty much it okay so
i'm ambitious guy
but not uh athlete no smart smart i like
smart and other girls can't be chasing
him no yeah i like attractive guys so
usually the guys that i like are being
chased by others but i feel like with
athletes they're just like you know they
have a girl in their dms all the time
and they're always at parties and stuff
i don't want somebody who's like
partying all the time um so you want to
stay at home with dad
yeah i like that are we talking pro
let's make make the distinction real
fast are we talking pro athletes or
i mean athletic build is fine i like
athletic build but athlete as in like
they play a sport i don't want somebody
who plays the sport okay
even recreationally i play flag football
on saturdays
yeah like a hobby is fine yeah yeah
you're talking about professionally at a
high level yeah yeah i'm just kidding
guys i don't play fly football uh so
okay cool pearly what about you
um
i would say like valley like having
similar values is really important to me
um getting along with my family
um work ethic and like i feel like it's
dishonest to say like there's no minimum
like level of attractiveness that you
look for
but yeah that's like usually what i look
for
what made you choose your last boyfriend
um
it's actually funny we
had very similar like senses of humor
i was gonna tell this story but i
decided not to but now this is my
channel we talk about what i want to
so
i'm about to tell the story
first time like one of the first times
we hung out
i say i fell in love with him because
of like we we decided to do a fake
argument like in public so we would
argue over like
like you know like pretending one of us
cheated and just having this fake super
loud public argument and
it was just funny because i remember
thinking wow there's no one else on the
planet that would think this is funny
and do this with me
so
yeah funny story um that was like the
first thing like i noticed about him
and
i don't know i just really
like admired like his work ethic too so
that's probably what attracted me to him
okay are we gonna not say the biggest
reason
why he's kind of famous too i don't know
if you want to say you don't have to say
it on air but he's kind of famous oh wow
um well i mean i wouldn't have met him
if he wasn't yeah yeah yeah so that's
the thing like i slid into his dms so i
can't i can't say that wasn't at all
attractive because
that that was how i met him you know
i i can't say that wasn't like part of
it well they know right don't they know
who your boyfriend is the people who was
her ex her ex was um i don't know if
they do or not um
yeah someone is going to put it i
already know someone cia or homeland
security's going to like
type it in and say oh that's another
important uh okay fair enough okay so
similar values okay
foreign
supportive ambitious
open-minded period
no clap back i was waiting for like no
more questions wait i'll just write
notes um how tall
i'm five eight i need you to be a little
only so i'm like three and four and one
yeah six in a six and a half oh my gosh
gosh how how do people watch this whole
show please how much a year how much
yeah i don't care about no no ambitious
if you're ambitious we don't get it
either way like i don't really look at
how much you make a year ambitious
you're gonna yeah like i said you know
we can't get either way and supported
and open-minded because i can't come you
can't come with me with your
one-track mind i'm not like that
so we're just gonna clash it if
not let's let's make it a little easier
does he have to make more money than you
at least i don't know you can make it so
i'm gonna
skip over places where i didn't really
talk because yeah
okay
and that is the secret guys suck her
dick all right let's uh let's go
damn
all right what else do we got uh
anything else chris all right next one
okay so last question here ladies
so
if you had to find this guy
what'd you share him with other women
uh well she went last time right yeah
yeah it's uh it's your turn tough
questions
here we go
would you share him of the night would i
share him
if my man is genuinely for me
probably after 10 years because i get
bored
i will just don't get bored five to ten
yeah cause you gotta spice it up
what if you get bored in first year well
that's your business you're out
why would you get bored in the first
year there's so much to me like
no why would you get bored of me if you
get bored of me you're not for me so yes
i'll answer that question later so yes
after five years
yeah
okay i wouldn't mind it i like girls
clothes phone you know what i'm saying
but i'm very jealous like so this is
you don't got to tell me if you're doing
dick spells on dudes
[Music]
oh i might have skipped this
i might have skipped this part
but
yeah this girl kept talking about like
voodoo and like dick spells and all this
stuff and i was just
so bored so bored when they were talking
about this i will skip over it again
okay welcome i don't think no spells on
nobody free will did not get their will
hard i get you uh the super vic the
super big welcome member i became a
youtube member welcome to the fresh and
fit fam hopefully you don't get your
dick spelled yet
the energy in the podcast is amazing bro
thank you hey man thank you so much bro
man we keep it positive right here man
y'all can't bring us down man seven
thousand five hundred you guys in here
guys don't forget for the people that
are new here from all the other hating
channels this is like the video please
comment below that you guys are frauds
sugar daddies whatever you want to say
guys check us out help us with the
engagement um so uh okay
okay so you would not share him okay
fair enough no no she's like okay oh
after five years sorry they're an amount
okay all right what'd you share here
you know damn well i'm not sure i mean
my dude sorry
thank you for the donation guys
i'm nervous about i just paid six months
rent in europe
my checking account is low so i really
appreciate every single donation like so
much
[Music]
oh
okay so in other words she ain't sharing
[ __ ] fair enough no here he is what
about you
no
no i had too good of an example of a
father growing up like honestly
not many people have that yeah i have
like i'm so lucky i had such a great
example of a dad that it really like
gives me something to look for in a
husband
so so so okay question though
how would you know for that cheater or
not
it's funny
no it's it's funny it's funny because
this is what people always say um and i
think like if that's how you view the
world you're just gonna like assume
that's what guys do but my dad doesn't
even drink he doesn't have any social
media my dad is a very unique person um
and like literally we just i have nine
siblings we live on a big piece of land
and it's like don't talk to anybody oh
so i don't know i just i know my dad and
like he would never do that that man put
your mama to work
i was damned by the first one
yeah i mean some some were adopted so
like they weren't all oh oh
okay yeah that one percent for real like
that real genuine love one percent
that's where are you from it might that
might be 200 percent but
you never really know but in your case
but i believe what i believe like of
course times have changed how with your
parents yeah
um
i have to think my mom's around 50. my
dad's around 55. and you live on a
isolated like form you said um we live
on 40 acres
so
we live 45
i'm sorry i didn't add this but we live
45 minutes from chicago it's not
like completely the middle of nowhere i
wouldn't say it's a farm we got more
like four-wheeling and stuff i'm like
dirt biking
girlfriend maybe
i want to be her friend maybe isolated
that far out and is that big maybe he
would get caught if you guys want
somebody i just i think when like you're
dealing with successful people there's
like two types that i've noticed there's
like kind of the corporate like fast
life type and then there's the type that
just makes their money and doesn't want
to deal with people right
and my dad like he's super successful
like he's probably in the top half a
percent of earners like worldwide or
like in the us
and yeah he just like made his money
that means over five hundred thousand
dollars a year guys yep
yeah i mean that's awesome yeah so i
just had a really great example of a
father growing up cool that's why she
dropped her boyfriend i need your money
[ __ ] oh kicked him out take care of
your face
yes
the farm get out of here i was getting
irritated because i was like that's not
what happened i was moving
i was moving
i got my money right no i did not
okay um moving on um cool so she would
not share would you share no i don't
want to share
but you never know i might want to spice
it up later on down the road right off
rip no i'm not sure your minds oh
okay and how long would you need to to
decide if you're going to share with
five year roll for you as well or i mean
like if you want to try something
different you it's fair can you discuss
it i don't know careful marriage
yeah
okay
okay all right um
no
thank you but um maybe down the road but
like within age because if there's
something you're trying to try like we
can get a book
we can look it up and we can try it we
can go search it we can do whatever you
want to do pull it out whatever you're
doing but like not you shouldn't be
getting bored of somebody like that
quick i think five years is still quick
because like how are you getting bored
already there's a lot of things you
could do old people be doing all these
types of things how are you bored i'm
just going to go to barnes and noble hey
uh i'm having a problem uh can you help
me with uh my boyfriend
we got you go over there go there
whatever you can google it there's
it and also first of all i think some
people get bored because they're afraid
to ask their significant other for
something they like and i feel like
that's why people get bored in
relationships if you want something
don't shy around it because
there's a lot of people that will do it
for you just saying i'm saying like
yours can go by you might find out he
want to do whatever
if you
it like i'll tell you this the reason
why guys lie
and i don't want to get too deep into
this because i want you guys to answer
questions organically without me
influencing anything but uh
from doing hundreds of interviews women
can't really handle the truth yeah i'll
be honest
i don't tell the truth because there are
consequences to the truth
it's like basically what he's saying
men don't tell you the truth because
there are consequences to telling the
truth guys there's consequences to being
a good person
again characters rare people that do the
right thing when no one's watching
that's rare so
so uh we'll see um all right cool um so
you so you were not sure no maybe down
the road but i'm gonna try whatever i
gotta do if barnes noble is still open
barnes and noble is still open they're
open i'll be like you'll pull out
your future yeah whatever are you about
down the road that'd be interesting
conversation with a book person with the
employees all right cool
oh my gosh okay let's skip a little bit
not now no no and not from my sperm
donor so
all right fellas you heard that hello
okay not
[Music]
what's up oh okay all right
uh all right let's play the let's play
the video real quick um
i ain't gonna lie someone in the chat
said she on that demon time for real i
was dying
[Music]
everybody's gonna come back for me for
this yeah
it's not good man it's funny
look at all those comments it's all
about do you i believe in jesus [ __ ] we
didn't ask that
all right so chris pulling up the video
right now guys so can you tell them a
little bit
yeah a genius man shout out to him he's
back on twitch right now but he could be
back in like six days five days whatever
but he did a video on about
why
man can [ __ ] anything yep and it's funny
because it's on a show all the time guys
may have a girl but they have the desire
and the thirst for a newbie and he goes
through it very
eloquently here you know with a speech
and shout out today man and yeah for you
guys that are wondering we had uh the
quan on uh last week yeah or was it the
week before week before yeah week before
yeah funny as [ __ ] one of our funniest
interviews guys after this is done go
check out our episode on how to not
uh get
how to date sugar babies without chicken
the solo one awesome and then the solo
one was the quan was the funniest
interview ever like check it out was it
was hilarious
chris uh minimize it real quick the um
his channel yeah sure oh yeah quick so
guys go support dakota man go stop this
channel shout out to him man shout out
to him cool all right so uh let's play
this real quick play the clip ah so look
right i'm pretty sure most of us if not
all of us
have heard women say
[ __ ]
will [ __ ]
anything
and i'm here to tell you ladies today
that that is the furthest thing
from a lie that is absolutely correct
but look i'm gonna tell y'all
now look right when i first heard a
woman say
[ __ ] will [ __ ] anything the first
thing i thought was it's me i'm [ __ ]
i'm not like little i'm not gonna sit
there a lot of y'all most things oh no
i wouldn't [ __ ] anything they gotta [ __ ]
anything
with the [ __ ] the first time i found
out i would [ __ ] anything is when i went
to a sex shop and saw
40 pounds of ass
and the first thing i thought is
i did that and you know how i know
[ __ ] will [ __ ] anything because
there's a such thing as 40
with no face right [ __ ] will really
[ __ ] anything did y'all [ __ ] forget
when y'all almost lost [ __ ] to the sex
stars you remember those realistic ass
ass sex dogs [ __ ] was going crazy over
this
[Laughter]
do you know how many times i had to tell
myself this is a doll just so i wouldn't
buy my [ __ ] i [ __ ] annabelle if i could
look ladies let me tell ya
as men
we know how to separate emotion
from sex
so if we want
sex we're gonna get it by any means you
know what i'm saying like brian ain't
gonna hold your [ __ ] as long as i got
50 cent i'm gonna get [ __ ] and not
trying like say princesses
as a man
if i'm looking for a girl
with a fat ass
then i'm gonna find a girl
with a fat ass
y'all [ __ ] about how she look and look
right i'm about to prove it to y'all
right now that y'all would do the same
take a look at
this right here
up for a reason another example
take a look at this one
[ __ ] to see this type of [ __ ]
see this type of [ __ ] right and be like
shout out to what do you call this
position
[Music]
and the main answer is always
child support
i'm [ __ ] crying
remember when that baby come out look
like one of the [ __ ] from the
hills have eyes then what but [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] because they just one
[ __ ] [ __ ] that can even do this now
see the thing is as a man we know what
we want and we go exactly for that why
do you think we go to the grocery store
with a list y'all women are the only
ones who like shopping around like st
francis if i say i want a girl with a
fat ass and 10 girls with a fat ass show
guess what i ain't [ __ ] 10 girls with
a fat ass y'all see y'all like yo i want
a man with a 10-inch dick 10 [ __ ] with
10-inch dicks show up like well i don't
know about him [ __ ] i don't even know
what that is to him
now ladies look
when y'all say
[ __ ] will [ __ ] anything
i agree
[ __ ] will [ __ ] anything
but i hate to break it to you ladies
y'all women try to empower each other by
saying [ __ ] like
all women are beautiful no the [ __ ] they
are
all the time
[ __ ] will [ __ ] anything [ __ ] are
realistic if we go out we all know we
are trying to [ __ ] and we know if we go
to a group of girls and one of them are
ugly guess what one of us got to take
one for the team
y'all [ __ ] will know your friend ugly
as hell
he'll be lucky to have you no no no no
no you will be lucky if he's yeah in
your body what's that man
what you know how many beasts man i
gotta take to the grave with me if i hit
this huge [ __ ] one time and then i'll
say she gonna see me in public talk
about something hey [ __ ] how you doing
[ __ ] how do you know my name
i thought my name was take my v card
from [ __ ] instagram [ __ ] i am under
witness protection the same way your fat
ass under fitness protection and we
basically end up in situations like that
because a man's take one for the team is
completely different from a woman's if a
man takes one foot a team that means he
gets [ __ ] anything he has to [ __ ] so
his friend can get some [ __ ] if a woman
is taking one for the team that means
she just sat out and didn't get any dick
while her friend did basically she sat
on the couch for her friend got [ __ ]
up let's see the thing is whenever y'all
say [ __ ] anything it's
because he's blocked on twitch right now
but we're back up on twitch guys
yeah refresh on switch guys if needed
loaded exchange he's got to take you on
dates he's got to spend time with you
he's got to um bring something to the
table of some kind of significance for
you to deal with him sexually now well
hold on let me continue on okay so
you'll have sex with him casually for a
while but at some point
and um oh yeah crazy over some dick
before
life-changing dick for real right yeah
so with one guy or many guys i mean
should i be lying if i said like more
than one it made me go crazy
but
again i can still
detach from it
sometimes
okay that's something that the point
we're trying to make here is that if a
woman can detach from sex it's almost
always to a temporary degree it's never
to the same level that a man can do it a
man can sport [ __ ] for 10 years and it
won't really bother him for a woman she
won't be able to go that long why don't
you say some woman as opposed to all of
them
if we were to take what 100 women 95 of
them would not be able to have sex for
that long without some type of emotional
attachment
i think some girls like lose that
attachment over time
like i think like initially you're right
but i've seen girls like where when i
knew them when they were younger like
they were super attached but then like
the more guys they like sleep with the
less like attached they get
and it's almost like
like learned if that makes sense i get
that but it always the point i'm trying
to make is that the shot clock always
comes up when they're done doing that
because and what i mean by that is let's
let's make it very clear i always say
sex is literally a handshake it's equal
value exchange but women almost i don't
think it's an equal value exchange um
because like a woman woman it decreases
her value in a guy it increases heads so
i think
that it's actually like
not
like i feel like
like a girl has more to lose from that
almost never treat sex as equal value
change you guys always treat it as a
value-loaded exchange he's got to take
you on dates he's got to spend time with
you he's got to um bring something to
the table of some kind of significance
for you to deal with him sexually now
well hold on let me continue on okay
so you'll have sex with him casually for
a while but at some point a woman's
emotions are going to get involved and
you're going to want him to either a
take you more seriously b take you out c
commit you to a degree or give you some
other kind of emotional investment very
rarely do women have sex with a guy and
just let him smash and then all right
you got to get out my spot girls most
girls are going to have some kind of
issue with that
rebound i don't know no i feel like it's
the words during sex like i feel like
march what what's what gets said during
sex that's what when we get attached to
like oh yeah i'm gonna this is my wife
oh yeah baby this is yeah but remember
remember we got it ladies we got to keep
the argument the the the the
our argument is that women rarely
can detach sexual emotion and if they do
it's never for it's always for a finite
amount of time yeah yeah but that's why
they can't detach because of what's
being said
they get i feel like women is the worst
what why it happens is irrelevant we're
just saying that it does happen
the why is is irrelevant the point we're
trying to make is
guys can do it no problem we are 100 men
can be detached from sex very easily for
women y'all have to it's almost a
learned skill for you guys and then the
women that i do know that you're talking
about that like
you know have sex like casually and
don't give a [ __ ] nine out of ten times
it's because maybe they're a porn star
maybe they're getting paid by sugar
daddies they're they're benefiting in
some degree very rarely are the girls
that smash all the time and do it long
term doing it without some kind of
compensation women are very intelligent
and know that their main agency is their
sexual access and for a girl
you would be stupid to not leverage it
against men for some something in return
and also when it happens they have
problems pair bonding like you said
before because they can't appear with
some one person because they've been
with so many so i get what you're saying
um it's common girl game like we break
it down on this podcast like men and
women it's a dance hey i got attention
and resources and then she's like well i
got sex okay let's see who can get the
commodity from the other without
necessarily giving up what they want
let's keep it real though most girls are
winning what are most guys doing oh
and then the girls still don't give them
no box or she does she give them that
starfish [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying like whatever
you know
maybe a [ __ ] if he's lucky you know
once every two years so like
most girls are winning in this aspect
and finessing guys and getting their
resources time and attention from them
without giving up the box we teach guys
how to get them
court
do they
kind of
i just
these girls must have more game than i
do
without necessarily giving up your
resources time and
remember we're going to turn to you guys
to grill us so don't worry they're next
so keep that in mind all right what
about you um i agree that men will [ __ ]
anything but i think women
they just have when they see someone
they have a purpose like they have more
like you said they have more of a like i
want this to come out of it 100 and even
if you don't willingly think i want this
to come out of it something is coming
out of it and you're you're continuing
it
but you can like be with people maybe
you're on a mission if you have a booty
call
[ __ ] buddy that you can easily detach
from you're just doing that to pass time
people do that but it doesn't happen
that often sometimes that person is what
you're supposed to be with and you stay
with them
but women have a motive i think all
women have a motive to get something it
can be the littlest thing but i do think
women choose their man specifically for
a reason and men choose it for that
moment of pleasure and women are like
okay pleasure great what else you got
because i got a game you could do if you
could do it yeah because if you could do
it on your own in your free time then
you don't really you know
what i'm saying you don't really need it
like that so i just believe like women
just have more motive they have more
like intention of like why they want
something a man's like you know what i'm
just gonna do they don't really have a
necessary reason it don't matter if it's
a rebound a breakup or whatever they're
like i was doing that during my [ __ ] my
relationship whatever so
women
they're more selective men they're like
you know whatever
whatever whatever is available at the
time it don't really matter whoever
cosign
period
what about you
i don't think they'll [ __ ] everything
because some people are more bougie with
their d like if somebody who's more like
have you mad
i feel like more attractive not to think
a better selection of women so i don't
think they'll have to like f anybody but
remember he's talking about most guys oh
okay okay so okay yeah all right you
know
naive girl
right they'll do it well it's not i
would argue it's not because she's naive
it's that she only sees a percentage of
men as viable candidates in the first
place
we talk on a podcast all the time that
uh i would i would argue 80 of men maybe
plus maybe more uh aren't virtually
invisible to most women sure
you know for example you know shirts and
stores uh
there's a cvs down the street from us
right and uh you know we go there every
now and then and there's this colombian
girl that works here she's pretty
attractive
fresh of course doing what he does
shoots a shot right but if we were to
reverse the roll right maybe have a girl
in there and have a guy that works at
that cvs and let's say you make 100
grand a year you make some kind of
serious money even if that guy's
attractive you're not going to take him
seriously as a as a potential candidate
you know what i'm saying so amanda what
i'm the
long story short here is
a large pool of women are visible to us
if it were versus for women a large pool
of men are not visible to you guys
because once a woman reaches
once a woman reaches a certain status a
lot of women are victims of their own
successes when it comes to dating you
make money but doors close a man makes
money doors open that's the difference
so i agree
okay
so i i threw you safe right there what's
your take on will guys smash anything
i mean i think all guys have like the
urge to smash anything it's just really
depends on if they want to do it or not
um but yeah like i could see what he's
saying okay all right fair enough um
what about you yes agree you know damn
well i could smash anything so why won't
you let him [ __ ] why don't you share
your guy then are you them because i'm
just like i just feel like i'm too much
like pay for it and then so you can feel
hurt because you got to come out of
pocket cause you hurt me oh [ __ ]
speaking of dick spells we got our
sponsor today roma hey
reaction videos
okay women get more attached than men
and virgins male or female get more
attached than kill us with high body
counts
uh anything else no
all right so uh next video first you
want to tell them about it so we're
gonna avoid uh
long beach griffey in the house so
basically guys you know what i'm saying
if you're an instagram model right and
you have kids
this is something something you need to
talk about okay now he did a very good
video on this and on the shoulder time
you have instagram models in the house
and it's like
it was around this time where i started
to get more comfortable i remember oh my
gosh i'm so tired i might have to react
to the second half of this tomorrow
but i remember the first half of the
show like
i was so uncomfortable in the second
half i like
gotten more of a groove he's gonna gonna
react to your videos in your pictures
and they're like oh
they'll get get over it when i get older
but in reality speaking
it's tough yep so shout out to long
beach griffy's gonna be on the show next
week guys yeah next week so here we go
mommy why are you naked right here
naked what are you talking about your
i got instagram clothes on and almost
all of these pictures
some of these pictures you just covering
up your private part give me the phone
give it i thought i told you to stay off
of instagram mommy i could see your
nipples through all your shirts you
shouldn't have been on instagram when
can i get on instagram never
you can never get on instagram okay
that's where mommy works do do you work
for fashion nova
they they under all your pictures what
no honey
mommy tags fashion nova in her pictures
so that they can comment which lets
other people know
that fashion nova notices me so how do
you get money do they send it through
the cash app how do you know about that
and sometimes
why are you even asking all of these
questions look never ever
ever get back on instagram okay okay
mommy but since i can't get on instagram
can i see your premium snapchat
go to your room
go to your room go to your room
oh my god
[Laughter]
all right
uh yeah he'll be here um okay um cool uh
so we'll go um we'll start we started
here last time right so we'll start here
this time okay guys
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna watch
until the end of this like section and
then i'm gonna go to bed unless
you guys want to motivate me with money
you don't have to you know i'm trying to
get to england
so if you guys wanted to send a donation
i would be highly motivated to keep
going
i just feel like kids will grow up
knowing that their parents speaking to
the mic kids will grow up knowing that
their parent or their mom is like you
know a bad [ __ ] so i feel like they
should get used to it but i mean you can
always
block your kids off of social media
if you feel like that
you know your content is a little bit
too
provocative for them the thing is yeah
how can you blow your kids if they go on
someone else's phone though
and their friends
that's your mom
i mean at this point yeah they just
gonna have to get over it and
you know get over it you know who your
mommy is i mean come on now what what
yeah she belongs to the streets
well
okay
so they're just gonna get over it yeah
at this point they just gonna have to
get over it grab my heart and do it one
time i got you she belongs to the
streets
um
there's no way to avoid your kids seeing
you on instagram but as far as telling
them not to have instagram and whatnot
blocking them that's not going to work
your kids are going to go to school and
you're going to have little kids
bullying them because they've seen your
mom on instagram naked
yeah they're going to say hey i saw your
mom's ass on the internet and then yeah
there's going to be some big titties
yeah
and in all honesty if you're not like
confident in what you're doing you're
not going to be able to teach your child
or like educate them properly on what
your career is
and at least try to control how that's
going to affect them
okay gotcha yeah um
like you said like you can't block your
children but
i feel like it depending on your
challenge but depending on your content
that you're doing it could be classy you
can do whatever i think you have to
explain to your children at a young age
like like you know after as they're
seeing that first of all 2021 everyone's
naked everyone's asses out you go to the
beach they see ass they're gonna see
titties people are gonna see it they
sucked on your titties they came out of
your vagina nothing new okay if anything
it's covered with something oh my gosh
do you see my face i'm like
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
in my life you know um
personally like but i will say this the
the i i would say that the difference is
that it's one thing if you're on the
beach and you look good and it's
whatever but it's when you take the
picture get the best angle filter it up
make it look as sexy as possible and
then put it on the internet
that's when it changes things oh
definitely i think it would change
things but honestly like
you would explain this already like if
it's your profession if it's your job
that you're serious about and if you're
not serious that [ __ ] should be cleared
off your page anyway you should switch
to mommy mode you clean it up you put
the turtleneck on you call it a day
don't matter where you are in flirting
you clean it up like regardless but if
it's a career you're serious about go
for it um my youngest brother he'd be
like yo i'm not letting my friends
follow you on the gram could you be
wearing bathing suits i'm like okay
you're a follow blocker that's fine um
but he feels some time away but he's
like so proud of me i do videos he's
like oh [ __ ] you did that you did that
that's dope but again he'll be like i
don't want my my friends we'd be
chilling and [ __ ] i don't want them like
stalking your page i get it my kid would
probably feel the same like mom what
were you doing in that video why are you
shaking ass and [ __ ] that won't even be
there by then like if i have kids you'd
be shaking ass
it's sometimes there you should check it
out you know a few little videos out
there you should check it out hey um oh
my god oh my god [ __ ] y'all tell me
because i'm not going you know ass is
definitely you know when you're doing
videos like sometimes i'm the girl the
fake girlfriend you know sometimes on
the girl in the back chain house
whatever
um but you should be clearing that up
regardless and by then if i'm you know
i'm still shaking my ass the check
better be higher you feel me because
then i'll explain to my kid hey you're
in this house that little ass shake that
you see over there your friends see it
pay for this house that your friends are
chilling in okay okay i have a question
um if you had a daughter like would you
care if she did the same thing
um
no because like honestly being
supportive is number one i try to like
manage everything that i do now like
like i have a man he's really super
supportive he sees my videos i was
dancing and he's like yo you killed that
[ __ ] because in the end like anything
that i do it's like my choice i do what
i want if i had a daughter which i want
boys but if i did have a daughter you
know i would explain like you still have
to respect yourself everyone has a limit
you should respect yourself and like so
people respect you could you be doing
stuff some people just have less respect
for you for what you you do
so if that's something you want to do
total support i'll show up to every
single shoe everything
oh my gosh sometimes i'm like ladies yes
or no
she was actually really nice i liked her
but
yes or no you got like respect yourself
don't let people do nothing touch you
nothing you're not comfortable like
chris um kris kardashian or jenner
like because she's going to the shoots
with like oh yeah
i would totally go i've been to shoots
where i've seen models literally bring
like their mom or anybody they don't
matter bring whoever you want i would
support and obviously you can't be a
hypocrite i feel like your kids anyway
you should be as honest and transparent
as possible because if i was to say hey
you cannot do this how dare you i'm like
mom i seen you on the youtube you were
sick like that anyway i feel like
support 100 do you feel like there's
like repercussions later for that sort
of thing or no um not necessarily
because like my i don't know people in
my family are pretty religious uh my
grandma's religious she's like she
thinks a bikini is like too much
sometimes she's like oh my god why are
you it's a bikini she's never seen one
like that before she didn't even know
what a thong was until like last month
dead ass so
um not really i'm i don't do nudity you
know what i mean i don't have like no
unless it was like middle school you
know a little pic or something it was
like a little it was a sports bra wait
anything else she said middle school
what there ain't nothing out there you
know what i mean um so for me i know my
limits everyone should know their limits
or what they want out there because once
it's up there
someone's gonna see it you know your
name speak your name is the only thing
you get so
bring value to it don't bring shame to
it you don't get that back you gotta
really build that up well the one thing
i do see with each generation is that
like each generation pushes it a little
bit further in terms of like taking your
clothes off you know what i mean like i
was kind of shocked when like the thong
bikinis came out but that's like super
normal now yeah like teenagers and i
remember like when two pieces came out
like when i was in high school like the
generation before was super like thrown
off um
yeah definitely with that but you should
also with age you should also be knowing
what's going on i feel like a lot of
parents don't know what goes on
currently in their children's life
because it's so changing so like to
somebody else they're like oh my god
like that is like a lot but if you're
currently growing with the change you
kind of have a different mindset right
well it's hard to monitor like as a
parent how do you monitor like snapchat
well i'd be i'm like on there you know
what i mean so if i'm seeing something
i'm on social media i'm not gonna just
be like i'm off social media so my kid
can have it i'm seeing what you're
seeing i'm gonna check that algorithm
just as much you are i'm like hey
what's up and i think um parents should
also check on their kids and i did
regularly i don't think parents ask i
know my parents said they're amazing but
they weren't like
what's going on are you yeah like what's
going on like what's on your head like
you would you see because there's some
stuff on the internet i'm not gonna like
crazy stuff that i'm like what am i
seeing so same thing gotta be
transparent with your kids okay
yo i'm not gonna lie you know in school
right you mean those pokemon cards yeah
and like uh they've been trading cards
like here's the gyarados here's the
pikachu
instagram this is your mom
this is your mom
yeah yeah it's it's changing the
conversation on the play schoolyards you
know what i'm saying so
um
yeah i feel like we're in a new
generation so everything is like yeah
people are more showy on social media
back then i feel like our parents like
if you ever heard a freak nick back in
the day parents used to go to freak dick
in the 90s and stuff they didn't have
social media to post it but they took
pictures and stuff now everything is on
like social media and stuff so
everything is more like stuck on there
so yeah you definitely should have
limitations on what you do i feel like
bikini pictures aren't too bad unless
you're like you know showing too much or
whatever but
definitely limitations okay yeah
um i think there's a lot of long-term
repercussions when you post like sexual
pictures online that people don't really
take into account when they start it
um
so like that's kind of my view on it
like i can understand like why people do
it because a lot of times like maybe
they're in a not good situation and they
see that as like a way to get out
um but i don't know i think like when
you're 45 50 you don't really want your
legacy to be like butt pictures and like
you know
and the other thing is i think a lot of
times girls confuse sexual attention and
relationship attention from men
um so like guys will give you attention
but they have no intention of ever like
wifing you or like putting your ring out
they'll even date you and have no
intention of ever putting a ring on it
so like girls will post something and
they get all this validation and they
think wow like this is great you know
like all these guys are talking to me
but all he wants is to hook up with you
so they're like using you essentially
damn son where'd you find this okay all
right all right all right uh okay um
what's your take on it i just feel like
mic drop
oh my gosh only girl in there with half
a brain cell um no that was mean some of
them are nice but
sorry that was mean thank you jan
thank you so much
thank you oh my gosh
um i'm
seriously like the donations for europe
helped so much i seriously appreciate it
like with all my heart
i mean
what's the difference between first of
all what's the instagram model second of
all
and then second of all what's the
difference between the song you're
wearing and then when you go to an arts
museum and you see titties oh my gosh
this argument i'm not even gonna play
the whole thing but it drove me crazy
because it's like she was kind of
compared like
nudity
in an art museum to like nudity
for only fans
she's like what's the difference i'm
like what
like why are we arguing about this are
you gonna be mona lisa in the museum
like what does that matter
like clearly clearly there is a
difference like what what oh my gosh
i was literally or would you want to
party would you want to be that like at
the statue at the museum yes
i mean
oh yeah
art is subject we're not going to go to
exactly we're not going to go into
religion because it's you know it gets
really yeah let's stay off that topic
they're trying to keep our d's working
but i'm just saying like
adam and eve naked like
the body i don't you know a lot of
things get manipulated you know
throughout time
but if you go to an arts museum you can
see naked bodies
so i mean and that's from how many years
ago and that's been shown to questions
and i just feel like those statues do
they have kids
maybe they do but they're deceased we
can't we don't know we can't ask them
oh my gosh i just remember sitting there
thinking like this is the dumbest
argument and most irrelevant argument
i've ever heard we're going to compare
only fans
to like statues well here's here's the
thing you don't know because you don't
know who they are anonymity
that's the key okay that's true but
what's the difference between posting
you're you breastfeeding your child
online like why do we have to explain
this there's a difference there's
clearly a difference
and with your
your child sees that compared to you in
a bathing suit are you
showing it you're still putting because
one's for sexual attention one
i wouldn't want to put either online to
be honest but
one is clearly for sexual attention one
you know it's just like natural that out
there okay so your your son's friends
are gonna be like hi you're a breast fed
okay like what happened with you well
here's here's the argument yeah uh
and just the challenge because i i see
that from the logic standpoint
one picture is to elicit sexual
attention from knobs of gender the other
picture repulsive sexual attention from
the opposite gender i know but that's
subjective because somebody could that's
subjective the one in a million guys has
turned on like
get out get out of here
like you know you're still showing your
tit it doesn't matter if there's a kid
in there or not yeah but i would i would
like a smaller number
the fact that a girl is breastfeeding a
baby and she's like just coming out of
pregnancy is not going to have the same
sexual arousal as a girl that puts her
picture on the internet that's showing
her boobs in her body men [ __ ] anything
and men will [ __ ] pregnant women yes
this is true this is true but what like
a smaller degree of man yeah like
people are still gonna if okay
here's the thing you put locks you you
lock the door even though people can
still break in but the reason why you
put the lock is it mitigates
the chances of you getting robbed and if
someone should try
their ability to do so they got to do
some work to do it
most guys are not going to find that
arousing or attractive so most guys are
like ah no so there's still a buffer
there to to some degree versus like you
know what i'm saying like for if you
okay because we've had a couple girls
come into the podcast like well
no matter how unsexy i dress
they still hit on me they still say hey
girl come here and all this other stuff
well i'll tell you this going out with
the what the okay nobody nobody heard me
cause i didn't say it loud enough but i
was thinking i said that must be nice
like
that does not happen to me with the
rocky gray sweatpants right like running
down the street you know
she was laughing she was like i was like
i do not know what that's like she was
like no one else heard my joke but it
was funny it was funny i swear you know
what i'm saying you're gonna get way
less attention than if you were that
short red dress with heels are you still
going to get hit on yes guys will be
guys but but we're all about mitigating
riskier
and you're right there's levels of this
[ __ ] so it's like
like you said what's an this is
something i disagree with anything worth
having comes with risk like
life is a risk so they're like this is
how shows like this work
let me give you every single stat that's
scary and fear-mongering and like shows
the negative side of humans
women whatever it is
don't ever make these decisions because
of risk like
people are people everyone comes with a
risk well i know what you said what i
said
there's levels i mean what's the answer
oh shoot i forgot we were talking about
only fans i'm getting tired don't do
only fans
sorry
model like there are some who that
where's tasteful like is there there's
an art you can tell that
it's not just ass like i'm just trying
to yeah editorials
it is
such a dumb argument
such a dumb argument
like
let's just talk about the one in a
million like it's not that
i'm just joking i'm joking
but um yeah it's this is true this is i
feel like there's levels to this
okay i would argue on the art side
there's there's more anonymity thank you
for the five dollars oh my gosh i
appreciate it so much
yay thank you guys seriously they really
help trying to get to europe like if you
were to look at a sculpture of a woman's
body most of the time the head is cut
off or if they do show her like yeah i
don't know who that is you know what i'm
saying it's just the body that yeah but
you're still gonna get rock hard ain't
it like yeah just gonna be like them not
like like a statue is not gonna elicit
the same like simulations of one put
purposely putting sexy photos of herself
with her link right there so you can
click it and look at the rest of her
stuff like oh god this is hot you know
it's not the same brick squad you guys
said it too you guys said face down ass
well not you guys but you know face down
ass up so you still see the body you see
me i'm so irritated
i'm so irritated like this is the
dumbest argument
bro that's what he said to mitigate risk
yeah i know i
i'm getting tired i was more talking
about when they're like
women do this women do that
no girls should not do only fans that's
just not
that's just not wise we're getting that
thing
no why so there's a face so we need a
face now we don't need a face let me
know guys i need to know these things
like a statue of art is not gonna do the
same as an instagram photo
why does he have to explain this
he should not have to explain this
where because because one
one is a statue the other one and you
don't know who the hell she is you can't
look at her other pictures whatever
the other is a sexy photo that has you
tagged that has an instagram profile
attached to it and you're like okay i
could look at the rest of her portfolio
as well
that girl might be attainable maybe not
in right now but in the near future so
you never know it might be a yeah you
look at her in a [ __ ] toga you're
like damn that [ __ ] died a millennial
though i can't bang her
instagram oh she's still alive
i could shoot myself
um
well since i already have a son and i'm
working in the sex industry so obviously
i i don't give a [ __ ] i love you you
know what i'm saying probably one day he
will see this podcast oh sorry um
somebody in the chat asked me
why you're up also i thought your daddy
has money you don't have to work
adam come here
stop lying to the people
you know we have to work
don't have to because that's what they
think so they're right
oh my gosh
no what the
he's just trying to embarrass me on my
stream he always does this um no we
still have to work it'd be nice
if my dad would fund my entire europe
trip that'd be nice
um okay
sorry i'm gonna continue but
legacy at the end of the day i got to do
what i got to do to make ends meet i'm
i'm dolo with it you feel me so
if i have to go ahead and shake some ass
and
all right that's how i pay them
you know what i'm saying i'm not at a
call center i'm not doing other things
you know what i would want to do is my
business and paint for people houses and
[ __ ] like that but
i'm not there
so till i get there you understand what
i'm saying like he's gonna just have to
understand it is what it is if they make
fun of you i'm sorry for it beat the ass
you got it
you got it gangsta like come on
listen i remember i was what third grade
that's the first i've heard of that if
they make fun you beat their ass [ __ ] it
i'm being serious listen
third grade
the guy next to me looked at me and said
your mom's a [ __ ]
i looked at him and i said i got you
after school i beat the dog [ __ ] out of
him so it's just you know what i'm
saying we lived very different lives
we lived very different lives me and
this girl
i've never been in a fight i hope to
never be in a fight you wanna talk [ __ ]
you're gonna get your eyes beat that's
it so that's what he gonna learn to do
you want to talk [ __ ] about my mama i
got you i will say this real quick um
are you on only fans too or no um
actually me and sterling are actually
gonna work on um fixing my page up
because i paused it i haven't really
been shut up sterling it's our boy
sterling man
yeah yeah he's he's uh he's running only
fans um helping out girls with managing
their stuff so yeah hey that's a good
guy to have on your side i'll tell you
all that yeah so um okay so
he's gonna help you get on it we're
gonna
you know my instagram right now is like
it's mediocre you're not going to see my
stripper [ __ ] like that i have one
stripper post so you know where i work
at so you could come find me but that's
it
you know what i'm saying i don't sit
there and be like come tell me no promo
no marketing no i mean
i i have yeah i feel y'all but like i'm
gonna be real with y'all i made my own
clientele within my seven years that i
feel like i don't need to promote right
you know what i'm saying yeah like
people come to see me because they know
who i am
so i'm chasing all right do you want you
want to tell them
or no booby trap on the river
[Applause]
and watch me hang from the
all right uh super chats real quick um
okay uh exploring the map if you're
getting 50k for your assets that's the
difference model and instagram as well
as after the age of 29 you put them back
onto the street due to the bs okay uh
who else we got anything else okay so
ladies that was your turn to ask
questions for the guys on the panel yes
you guys think of a question uh oh oh
[ __ ] you ready to go
i've been holding this question since
y'all told me the whole day okay you
know what i'm saying what since men are
able to detach from sex right
how can uh what's the question how can
you like like what makes a w a girl
worth it to you
that you could put your emotions in
i want to know that
okay
am i making sense no no
at what point are you going to uh invest
in a woman and get the emotional
investment in but you know like like
what sparks that in a man like what
makes you see her
making her look different from all the
other [ __ ] since we know men will
[ __ ] anything like i just really want to
know
her stand up basically yeah so yeah we
said this last last night on the show as
well and basically uh we were saying
that consideration and adding value say
to sex so for example let's say you're
with a chick right and you made it for
the first time you smash all right
that's cool but what happens next is she
going to help you with your business
you know maybe clean your room this can
help you like basically be a helper in
your life that point you become more
than just a [ __ ] buddy you know you're
you know what she's an asset to my life
you know what i can't get rid of her
anymore i got to be with her because she
i smell like that
adam can you stop whistling
i just hate it when i'm streaming
other girls don't so heist nano is you
be feminine you understand you know what
if the guy i'm dating is into i don't
know um
boxing right i'm gonna go support my
boss matches i'm gonna bring him uh some
water some some ice so that when he
needs to take a break i got you babe
boom just things like that you know help
a guy and say you know what damn she's
more she more to me than just sex she
adds value to my life so i would say
adding value is definitely one thing
that will make you stand out and
secondly be considerate understand you
know what yes um i actually agree with
that i think that just being nice and
helpful goes a long way i don't think
it's always cooking and cleaning that
like guys want i think sometimes it is
sometimes it isn't like some guys just
hire that they don't care
um
but just like being helpful i think i'm
gonna give him what he wants but it's
what he actually needs at this point in
time
so
uh so every guy's oh she's like oh i
wanna know i i love hearing his comments
yeah okay are you going to put a spell
on me
tell me a reason mario
if you don't see it if y'all don't see
me tomorrow
you guys know what i'm gonna be here
tomorrow and yeah i'm gonna do those
three shows go ahead thank you very much
i hope so uh no i mean what it comes
down to is uh i'll be honest most women
are a liability not an asset so uh the
biggest thing is
guy game is being able to attain the
girl girl game is being able to retain
the guy after sex
so you're going to keep a guy around
post-sex if you uh add value to that
guy's life where he can't necessarily
operate the same level without you being
by his side so
i think a lot of women have this
ideology and we asked you guys earlier
hey where does marriage stack up on your
list of uh uh uh importance right what
priority is it for you and we we
expected you guys to say pretty much at
the bottom
i need you guys to elevate it to the top
if you want to be kept around that's the
key if you want to get married you have
to elevate it to the top priority
because when you elevate it well i just
wanted to know like what does that look
like
like what does it look like elevating
marriage to the top priority like let's
say today i was gonna do that
most girls work right so let's say i
work 40 hours a week
i'm not going to be able to work on
dating more than 40 hours a week like
i'd have to be going on dates like seven
days like
i was just thinking what does that look
like what's that priority what you're
doing is you are now acquiescing to the
man that you are going to be with when
you acquiesce to his frame and his
reality that's when you become an asset
because now
you're helping him
make that reality not just better for
him but for you too
when a man becomes better the woman
benefits as a byproduct when the woman
becomes better she starts to look at
other potential suitors that's the
difference because you guys are always
looking
for someone who's better than you men we
don't care about that are we're
satisfied with a girl that can help us
be the best that we can be a girl isn't
satisfied until she finds the best that
she can get
so that is why it's so important for the
man to be the leader because if the
woman's a leader
yeah just a matter of time until he's
going to get replaced i always say
men lead women follow if a woman leads
she's going to lead you all right to the
end of that goddamn relationship each
and every one of you guys mentioned hey
ambition
you guys want to know why ambition is so
important to women because ambition has
a direct reflection on a man's ability
to provide long-term and provide
security provisioning et cetera women
look for security and provisioning i
know you guys don't want to overtly say
i need another money you ain't going to
say that you're going to say i want a
guy that's ambitious it's more
politically correct it sounds good he
gives guys but it's not it's not about
money this is one of my caveats
with the manosphere and like red pill
whatever we are not attracted to money
if a guy had a trust fund okay
and he he knew he was going to be good
the rest of his life we're not attracted
to that we're attracted to competence
maybe power i don't know leadership all
of those traits were attracted to it is
not money by itself
so
i hate it when they say money because
it's not money
dance that might not have their money
together to get their [ __ ] together but
the point is is that just like we said
before depending on hot the girl is
might be mba level 24 second shot clock
you got to get your [ __ ] together if
she's not the hottest girl eh you might
get a college ncaa shot clock what 42
seconds 48 seconds to shoot the shot but
the point is that there's always a time
clock so for a woman
your goal is you've got to um
provide value to that man yeah that's
the biggest thing one is right all the
rappers and celebrities that you see
dating girls
their girls actually help them with
their their lifestyle their career
behind the scenes and their their big
reason why they became so big because
when they were smaller they would help
them maybe with their gigs driving to
certain events and
they'll take care of the kids now now
that they made it they got them for life
because they were different in the very
beginning helping them with their
mission and their purpose so that alone
say you know what
she might not be the baddest chick ever
but she's there for me at the very
beginning helping help me with you know
with my mission so you know what i got
her for life
okay
people are saying come on pearl
it's money lies
you ain't gonna be with no man that only
makes 50k a year pearl it may not be
money but women don't f with broke guys
so money helps does money help sure sure
but guys
if it was money alone
the women would see no difference
between a tr a trust fund baby right a
guy who just woke up one day
had a trust fund
and
the ceo of a company like if they had
the same like let's say even the ceo of
the company had less money
but he had those qualities that girls
look for trust fund baby who does
nothing
guarantee guaranteed most women would
pick the ceo
yeah it just comes down to kind of
knowing knowing your guy and knowing
what what uh what a what maybe uh
a hole is that could keep him from
operating at the highest level now
one thing though he has to be the right
guy that understands and knows what he
wants because for example okay
for that then it don't matter
where you know what i want one girl
who's gonna help me with my purpose i'm
ready for it but some guys aren't yeah
because they're mad ungrateful you will
do any and everything for a guy and i've
been in very relationships you know what
i'm saying yeah i know who you are
yeah disrespectful as [ __ ] ungrateful
[ __ ] and that's it
i don't get it why if somebody genuinely
adds value to your life why do you [ __ ]
on them you know but not you guys you
know what i'm saying no wait wait wait
wait wait so i gotta answer this
question by the way but go ahead chris
you got some so was um i didn't buy you
um same thing how he said being
considerate being being the [ __ ] for
him being on call being submissive doing
everything that you know that will make
this [ __ ] happy and for you but then
again there's the guys what i need i
need an adrenaline rush
one donation
i won't go to bed right away i'll keep
i'll keep going
no pressure at all there's not a ton of
people in the chat i could go to bed
finish this tomorrow
but every time i get a donation i get an
adrenaline rush and motivates me to keep
going
opposite side where
it just gets taken you get take
advantage of it
no no my you like you said earlier has
to be the right guy is going to actually
appreciate it because once again
girls have a problem choosing the right
guy and you get you as a bad boy
looks taller
oh all right next to him
because we asked you guys this about
earlier too would you share the guy um
not to pry too much but uh the last guy
that was involved i don't want no
details or whatever i just want some
simple stuff uh was he a high earner
no we were both the same
well
i know you're
dancers in miami do pretty well so six
figures
was he a six figure earner no no he
wasn't it was average average average
guy 60k yeah mike um oh yeah okay 60k
and um was he attractive uh he is very
attractive okay but um
tall tall
actually he was my same height that was
the first time okay it was a first timer
i'm usually always with like six four
and up like but i was like you know what
i want to give this guy a chance he's
simple you know i've never really been
with a son
it's not that he cheated oh he didn't
cheat
i just it's just being with me and
you don't have a kid so you don't know
what it's like to be a father you know
what i'm saying i've been through that
so you know for somebody to sit there
and say your child is draining me when
all i need you to do is just watch him
to go to sleep or you know to go to
sleep so i could come back and make my
bread how you could go in the morning to
go make your bread
to hear those words that my child drains
you i automatically just picked up all
my [ __ ] and left
because you're not the man for me yeah
because how are you going to sit here
and say that to me my child drains since
they [ __ ] won the first fourth the
first two months every three hours you
don't understand what i'm saying like
i had to sit there and be on call for my
baby so so you can't even put this [ __ ]
to sleep and you telling me that he's
draining you come on bro
was he like a stepdad
yeah your kid yeah he was for how long
for a good five months all right put
yourself in his shoes right remember he
just said he can't comprehend my new
pause
before i added my child into the
situation we were talking you understand
what
did the live
stop
huh
did the livestock hold up
the thing on the screen
okay guys i'm not even sure if the
livestocks or not but i think that's my
sign
i'm gonna do this tomorrow i'm gonna do
part two maybe the last
thing
um or the second time i was on i'm
getting tired
but
thanks for watching
you guys